[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
remember next bit they made that one
phone that one time
well razer a gaming company
bought next bit but hey i guess if red
can make a smartphone then pretty much
anyone else can too
and essentially this has been a really
interesting year for those new
smartphones and new smartphone companies
so it's official this
is the razer phone this is a smartphone
built entirely around gaming all the
hardware decisions all the specs all the
design the form factor and features are
all made with the idea of making gaming
as good as possible but as it turns out
a lot of those things
also make for pretty great everyday use
too first of all the build quality if
you've ever seen a razer gaming laptop
you've seen the matte black finish with
the logo on it this is that same finish
no the logo doesn't glow rgb or anything
crazy like that but i kind of like the
stealthy look even though it's kind of a
big phone it's pretty fingerprint
resistant and it kind of blends in and
being all metal all the way around it
has a sturdy literally rock solid feel
on the hand now one thing you may be
thinking is hey it's 2017 why doesn't
this new razer phone have edge to edge
displays like we're getting used to on
all these phones now
well this phone has big bezels
on purpose like i said their mindset is
gaming and gaming trying to hold a phone
with an edge to edge display can
actually be kind of tough there's not a
whole lot to rest your thumbs on so
instead they're giving us massive stereo
front-facing speakers flanking the
display on either side it's a place to
put your thumbs while gaming and they
also happen to sound absolutely
incredible loud full crisp and
surprisingly little distortion actually
at high volumes and you can even go into
the sound settings and mess with dolby
atmos settings so movie mode or music
mode or whatever you want to do just to
get the eq just right so yeah right off
the bat you can see the hardware is
built around making the gaming
experience great but that also means the
rest of using the phone benefits too the
only downside i really see with this
hardware is the buttons which are left
over from the next bit robin the
fingerprint reader and power button
combo on one side is kind of cool but
the cheap tiny plastic feeling volume
buttons on the other side definitely
aren't but let's talk about this display
though shall we
if i know anything about gaming it's
that we want the highest frame rate
possible at all times and razer knows
that so they've built as far as i know
the first phone to come to the us with
120 hertz display 120 frames per second
all the time on an android phone that's
incredible remember the ipad pro the new
ipad pro has that promotion display that
i've raved about and really liked in the
full review
this
has that all the time it's a 5.7 inch
2560 by 1440 ips display
ips because it's not yet possible to do
this high refresh rate with oled yet and
it checks all the normal box as being a
pretty good display it's decently bright
but pretty contrasty it's crispy and
then it's just
so liquid smooth everywhere i've never
seen android run smoother than it does
on a pixel on any other phone
until this razer phone now out the box
it will actually be set at a 90 hertz
refresh rate sort of striking a balance
between battery life and super
smoothness but of course i bumped it
right up to 120 hertz right away but
that's essentially just a max frame rate
so when you're not really using the
phone or it's just sitting on an image
or on the settings page or something
nothing's moving it drops to a lower
frame rate to save battery and then it
picks up immediately again when you
start touching it it's really impressive
variable frame rate stuff now not every
game will take full advantage of this
right off the bat but again razer knows
gaming pretty well and they have
connections they're working with big
game makers and developers to get all
these popular games optimized for 120
hertz so in the next couple weeks when i
see those updates i'm definitely going
to be testing that so the rest of the
specs since specs are pretty much the
holy grail when it comes to gaming
snapdragon 835
adreno 540
eight gigs of ram
64 gigs of internal storage
and a 4 000 milliamp hour battery that's
that last part is the most impressive i
think you already know that using 120
hertz display at full brightness with
graphically intensive games at 1440p
that will burn through battery pretty
fast having a massive battery is great
for gaming and for the rest of the phone
also in talking to razer they seem
pretty proud of their their cooling and
if you know gaming you know how
important thermals are to performance
and essentially what they've done is
created a heat sink design that uses the
entire metal frame of this phone to cool
the cpu which is really cool i'll leave
a benchmark for good measure if you guys
are curious about that but the bottom
line is performance should also be
really great for gaming and for real
life and then last but not least the
software experience on the razer phone
is pretty close to stock android with
just a couple of added features i'm a
pretty big fan of the strategy obviously
as i've said before and it works well
here no bloatware comes on this phone
the stock launcher is actually nova
launcher prime so you get a ton of
customization right out the box and
while it's launching with android 7.1
they are promising an android oreo
update first thing next year in quarter
one so that's another advantage to being
near stock the cameras on this phone i
don't expect that to be too much of a
focus no pun intended
because mostly they have nothing to do
with gaming right now but for what it's
worth there is a pair of 12 megapixel
cameras on the back f 1.75 on the main
camera f 2.6 on the secondary telephoto
lens and it's rocking an 8 megapixel f
2.8 wide angle front facing camera that
you can see in the speaker grill
definitely not slacking in the numbers
department but i'll say that's something
that's got to be tested for the full
review but i mean basically i'm i've
just been really impressed that they
thought of all this stuff
to go at their first try at a smartphone
and executed on it so well like did you
see the packaging this might be the best
smartphone packaging of any phone in
this price point maybe of any phone at
all right now
it's got some pretty sweet accessories
they're all braided cables and
individually packaged and with stickers
the whole deal well done razer it has
expandable storage
it has this this really nice subtle
chamfer all the way around the display
uh usbc fast charging no headphone jack
but it does come with an adapter with a
thx certified deck i don't know how much
weight you want to put in the thx
certified part but not bad no headphones
though but overall my impressions right
off the bat are pretty positive at this
thing i don't think i was expecting it
to be this good mostly because like i
said it's been really hard or really
interesting to get a new smartphone
company off the ground and do things
well but it seems to be worth noting
that razer isn't a new company and they
know what they do well already gaming
and they've built this phone around that
they have a following of people who have
the same tastes this phone could be a
really interesting buy for those people
to use every day and it turns out this
enthusiast phone might translate really
well to regular everyday use because all
those things that are good for gaming
are still good in the real world only
one way to find out though and that's
through testing so i'll be getting to
that for the full review make sure to
subscribe if you haven't already to be
among the first to see the full review
when it comes out but that's been it for
the first impressions either way thank
you for watching
talk to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]